The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
I was just thinking
of a story that
came to mind about the
woman who went on vacation.
And she said, "We
went to Majorca."
And her friend said to
her, "Where's that?"
And she said, "How
should I know?
We flew."
And today we're going to
fly through matrix algebra.
In other words, we're going
to devote an entire lecture
to the subject called
matrix algebra, which
is a rather fast pace
from one point of view.
From another point of view,
it's a rather slow pace
because hopefully, by this
stage in the development
of our course, we're
pretty well familiar
with what we mean by
the game of mathematics.
And hence, in
particular, if we now
try to make a structure
out of matrices,
we should be in
pretty good position
to generalize many
of our early remarks.
Let me say at the outset that
whereas matrices in general
can be m rows by n columns,
the interesting case
occurs when m and n are equal.
In other words, the
interesting case
is when a matrix
has the same number
of rows as it has columns.
And again, using
as our motivation
a system of equations, the
easiest way to see this
is that, for
example, if you have
a certain number of equations
and a certain number
of unknowns, the
really interesting case
occurs when you have
just as many equations
as you have unknowns.
For example, if you have
more unknowns than equations,
you usually have quite a
few degrees of freedom.
In other words, a
far-fetched case,
suppose I have one equation
with fifteen unknowns.
Then you see, I
can pick fourteen
of the unknowns in
general at random
and solve for the
fifteenth in terms
of the specific
choices of the fourteen
that I picked at random.
On the other hand, if I were to
have fifteen equations and just
one unknown, the chances are I
would have some contradictions.
Because after all,
with only one unknown,
I could only impose
one condition.
And therefore, given
fifteen conditions--
unless they were all
equivalent conditions--
I might wind up with
a contradiction.
So in general, the easiest
way to summarize this
is that when you have
more unknowns than you
have equations, you usually get
too many answers to a problem.
And if you have more equations
then you have unknowns,
you usually get too few
answers, where by too few,
you mean none.
So the interesting
case, as I say,
is when you have the same
number of unknowns as equations.
Motivating matrices
from this point of view,
the game of matrices will
be played in our course
as follows.
We will let the set S sub
n denote the set of all n
by n matrices.
In other words, n could
be 3. n could be 4.
It could be 2.
It could be 5.
But whatever value we
choose for n, for example,
S sub 5 would be what?
The set of all 5 by 5 matrices.
So we're just gonna
deal with a general n.
By the way, I should point
out that these computations
get kind of sticky.
So we will, for
illustrative purposes,
usually pick examples with
n equals 2 or n equals 3
just so that we can
see what's going on.
But the notation
that we'll use is
that if the matrix A
is a member of S sub
n, what does that mean?
A belongs to S
sub n means that A
is an n by n matrix, which
usually is written this way.
And if you wish to abbreviate
it, we just write what?
The square brackets and a sub
ij inside the brackets this way.
Now again, keep in mind
that to play any game,
it's not enough to
have the equipment.
We have to have the
rules which defines
for us how the terms behave.
So we're going to define
equality of two matrices
as follows.
Given the two
matrices A and B, we
will define them to be equal
if and only if entry by entry
they happen to be equal.
In other words, the
term in the i-th row,
j-th column of the
first matrix has
to be the same as the term
in the i-th row, j-th column
of the second matrix for all
possible values of i and j.
And again, if you
want to motivate
why we choose this
kind of a definition--
even though definitions do not
have to be defended-- notice
that as soon as you change
some of the coefficients--
if you change even one
coefficient of an equation
given n equations
with n unknowns,
as soon as you change
one of the coefficients,
you've changed the
system of equations.
Therefore, for these systems to
be exactly equal you want what?
Term by term equality.
And correspondingly, to
add two n by n matrices,
in other words to add the
matrix A to the matrix B,
we define the rule to be what?
That the sum of
these two matrices
is the matrix C where
each element of C
is obtained by the term by term
addition of the elements in A
and B. In other words,
we add two matrices
by adding them entry by entry.
In other words, we
add the two entries
in the first row,
first column to obtain
the entry in the first
row, first column
of the sum, et cetera.
In other words, we
add term by term.
As far as multiplication
is concerned-- and again,
this is the point I was
making in the last lecture
and which I like to
keep re-emphasizing
because it's very important.
One would like to say
something like, "Gee, it
was very natural to add
two matrices term by term.
Why don't we multiply
them term by term?"
And the answer is certainly
you could have made up
a game of matrices in which
the product of two matrices
was obtained by multiplying
the matrices term by term.
However, if we keep in
mind what problem we
want matrix multiplication
to solve-- in other words,
notice now, we are playing
the game of matrices the way
the real-life
scientist plays games,
not the way the abstract
mathematician plays games.
You see, in mathematics
what we essentially
say is, let's make up the rules
and we'll worry about models
that obey the rules later.
In real life we say, let's
look at a model that we need,
a physical, realistic model.
And then based on the
properties that this model has,
let's make up the abstract
rules that govern the system.
And what we saw in
the last lecture
was that the sensible definition
of matrix multiplication,
in terms of a chain rule, was
that to multiply two matrices,
to get the term in the
i-th row, j-th column,
you dot the i-th row
of the first matrix
with the j-th column
of the second matrix.
And the way we write that--
and again, this notation may
seem a little bit heavy to you.
But all it does is it
states symbolically what
we said in words last time.
What we're saying is
that to dot the i-th row
with the j-th column, notice
that the i-th row is always
prefixed by the first
subscript being i.
Whereas the second subscript k
can run the whole gamut from 1
through n.
In other words, the
second subscript
can denote any column you want.
Correspondingly, to
indicate that you've
stayed in the j-th column,
the row can be arbitrary.
And that means, again, that
the subscript k, denoting
the row of the B matrix, can
run the full gamut from 1 to n.
In other words,
this formal set-up
here simply says in
mathematical, concise language
the statement that we
said verbally before.
Namely, to find the i,j-th
term in the product,
dot the i-th row of the first
matrix with the j-th column
of the second matrix.
And again, I suspect
that the easiest
way to see all of
these things is
in terms of a specific example.
And again, the simplest
example I can think of
will involve the 2 by
2 case, n equals 2.
So by means of
illustration, let A
be the 2 by 2 matrix all
of whose entries are 1.
Let B be the 2 by 2 matrix
all whose entries are 1.
Except in the first row, second
column the entry will be a 2.
Now, my first claim
is that in terms
of our definition of
equality, matrix A
is unequal to matrix
B. Why is that?
Well, notice that they
differ in the what?
First row, second entry.
In other words a
sub 1,2, the entry
of A matrix in the first
row, second column, is 1.
Whereas the entry of the
B matrix in the first row,
second column is 2.
Don't say, gee, they
look equal almost
because three out of
the four match up.
Remember, equality by
definition says what?
Entry by entry.
Three out of four
isn't good enough.
It has to be all four.
Therefore, this matrix A
is not equal to matrix B.
How do we add two matrices?
Well, to add them,
we said that we
would add them entry by entry.
Therefore, the first row,
first column of the sum
should be obtained by adding
the first row, first column
terms in each matrix
together, et cetera.
And just going through this
quickly, we would get what?
1 plus 1 is 2.
1 plus 2 is 3.
1 plus 1 is 2 again.
1 plus 1 is still 2 over here.
In other words A
plus B in this case
would be the two by two
matrix [2, 3; 2, 2].
Now, how do we multiply
the two matrices A and B?
Remember what the rules
were for multiplication.
To multiply A by
B, to find the term
in the first row, first column,
we dot the first row of A
with the first column
of B. That gives us
1 times 1, which is 1, plus
1 times 1, which is also 1.
The sum is therefore 2.
So the entry in our first
row, first column is a 2.
To find the entry
which turns out
to be 3 in the first row, second
column, how do we do that?
We dot what?
We want what?
First row, second column.
We dot the first row of
A with the second column
B. We get 1 times
2 plus 1 times 1.
2 plus 1 is 3, et cetera.
Carrying out the
details, the matrix A
multiplied by the
matrix B in this case
would be the matrix [2, 3]
in the first row, [2, 3]
in the second row.
By the way, B times
A would involve what?
Writing the matrix B first
followed by the matrix A.
And leaving the
details for you, just
to check out for
yourselves, notice-- well,
let me just do one for you.
Suppose I want to see
what was in the first row,
first column here.
I would have to do what?
Dot the first row of B
with the first column of A,
the first row of B with
the first column of A.
That gives me 1 times 1
plus 2 times 1, which is 3.
And by the way, even if
I went no further here,
notice that already tells
me, in this case at least,
that A*B is unequal
to B*A. Why is that?
Because the entry
in the first row,
first column of A*B
happens to be 2.
The entry in the first row,
first column of B*A happens
to be 3.
And we've already seen that
for two matrices to be equal,
they must be equal
entry by entry.
And they're already
unequal in the entry
in the first row, first column.
So notice, by the way, that
matrix multiplication need not
be commutative.
And you see this is a glaring
distinction between matrix
multiplication and numerical
multiplication, where
when we multiply two
numbers, the product does not
depend on the order in
which they're written.
But when we multiply
two matrices,
our definition is
such that the product
does depend on the order
in which they're written.
And you might say, well
isn't that an awful thing?
Well, maybe it is.
But notice that once we pick
the definition that we want,
we have to let the properties
fall where they will.
And by the way, it
is nice to notice--
and again, I will
leave the details out.
They are in the notes.
You'll be checked on these in
the exercises and the like.
But the interesting
point is that most
of the rules of
numerical arithmetic
are obeyed by matrix arithmetic.
And let me just go
through a few of those
with you, just
mentioning what they are.
Notice, again, the wording here.
I call these
properties of the game
rather than, in terms of
our usual game notation,
the rules of the game.
Notice that we sort of
refer to things as being
rules when you make up
the game abstractly.
On the other hand, when
you start with a model
and tell what addition,
multiplication, and equality
means, from these
definitions you
deduce properties of the system.
So the properties of the game
of matrices, meaning what?
The properties based
on the interpretation
that we're giving this in
terms of the calculus course,
the systems of equations.
You see, there are other
ways of introducing matrices.
For the calculus
course, we elected
to do it in terms of
systems of equations.
But at any rate, you can
check the following things out
quite easily.
First of all, if A and
B are any two matrices,
A plus B is equal to B plus A.
And that follows, of course,
from the fact that when
you add two matrices,
you add them entry by
entry, and the entries
happen to be numbers.
And the sum of two
numbers does not
depend on the order in
which you write the numbers.
In other words A plus
B does equal B plus A.
Similarly, if you
add B plus C to A,
it's the same thing as if
you added C to A plus B.
In other words, the addition
of matrices is associative.
The answer does not depend
on the sum, does not
depend on voice inflection.
A plus (B plus C) is
the same as (A plus B)
plus C. Again, notice
how this obeys the rules
of ordinary arithmetic.
Thirdly, if I define
the zero matrix
to be the matrix each
of whose entries is 0,
then I claim that if I add the
zero matrix on to any matrix A,
the result must still
be the matrix A.
And this is also a
triviality to check.
Namely, how do you
add two matrices?
You add them term by term.
But every term in
the zero matrix is 0,
and adding 0 on to a number
doesn't change the number.
Consequently, if
you, term by term,
add 0 onto the entries
in A, you still
have the entries in A intact.
So A plus 0 is A.
And finally the
rule of inverses.
Namely, if A is the matrix each
of those entries we'll call
a sub i,j, then if I add minus
A onto A, the result will be 0,.
Where by minus A I mean what?
The matrix each of whose entries
is negative a_(i,j) The reason
being, again, that when you add
two matrices you add them term
by term.
Every time I add on the negative
of a number to the number
itself, I get the zero number.
Consequently, every entry in
the sum of A and negative A
will be 0.
And by definition,
that's the zero matrix.
Point I want to mention is
to observe that with the zero
matrix, defined as
we've defined it,
and the negative
of a matrix defined
as we have defined it, that
the rules for matrix addition
are exactly the same
structurally as the rules
for numerical addition.
And that means that with
respect to addition,
we cannot distinguish matrix
algebra from arithmetic
algebra, numerical algebra.
In fact, many of the rules of
multiplication for matrices
are the same as for numerical
multiplication as well.
Namely, one can show that
if you multiply the matrix
A by the product of
the matrices B and C,
that this is the same
as multiplying A times
B by the matrix C.
These can be checked
by longhand computation.
I have you do some of these
things in the exercises.
Similarly, one can prove
that matrix multiplication
is distributive.
That if you multiply a matrix
by the sum of two matrices,
A times (B plus C) is the same
as A times B plus A times C.
And another rule
that's interesting,
there is a matrix that plays
the role of the number 1.
And surprisingly enough,
it's not the matrix
all of whose entries are 1.
It's the matrix all
of whose entries
are 1 on the main diagonal
and 0's every place else.
That may sound surprising.
You say, "Gee, the zero matrix
is when I had all zeroes,
why shouldn't the unit matrix
be when I have all 1's?"
And the answer is, if we were
to multiply two matrices term
by term, then the unit
matrix would've been all 1's.
But remember, we agreed not to
multiply matrices term by term.
We agreed to do what?
Dot the i-th row of the
first with the j-th column
of a second.
And if we do that,
like it or not,
this is what the matrix
has to look like.
In other words, let me take
the matrix in the 3 by 3 case,
because that's
complicated enough
to have you see the overall
picture and simple enough
so it doesn't take
pages of computation.
Let me take the 3 by 3 matrix,
which I'll just quickly write
as [a, b, c; d, e, f; g, h, i]
and multiply that
by [1, 0, 0; 0, 1, 0; 0, 0, 1].
You see, that's the
matrix that has what?
1's in the main diagonal
and 0's every place else.
Look what happens.
When I look, for
example, for the term
in the second row,
third column--
second row, third column--
look what's going to happen?
The d multiplies 0,
that gives me zero.
The e multiplies
0, that gives me 0.
And the f multiplies
1, which gives me f.
In other words, the term in
the second row, third column
is going to be f, which
is exactly what it should
be if we claim that the
product matrix is going to be
the same as the first matrix.
In other words, notice
that this set up
is such that you're going
to get 0's every place
but when the term in
question comes up.
And I don't want to go through
that in too much detail for you
because I think that as you
just play with this thing,
you'll see it for yourself.
Let me do just quickly one more.
Suppose you wanted the term in
the third row, second column.
You see what's going
to happen here.
The g multiplies 0,
which yields a 0.
The h multiplies 1,
which yields an h.
And the i multiplies
a 0, which yields a 0.
So the dot product is
just going to be h itself,
as it should be.
And so you see,
what I'm saying is,
by my definition of
matrix multiplication,
if I define the matrix I sub n
to be the matrix each of whose
entries is 0, except, on
the main diagonal they're
1-- another way of writing that
is that the entries-- in fact,
we could write this way.
The entries, let's
call this delta_(i,j).
And what you're saying is that
delta_(i,j) is 0 when i is
unequal to j.
And it's equal to
1 when i equals j.
And what we're saying
is that if you define
I sub n to be that matrix,
if you multiply A by I sub n,
it's the same as
multiplying I sub n by A.
And the result will always be A.
By the way, one of
your first objections
might be, isn't this redundant?
Why do you have to write that A
times I sub n is the same as I
sub n times A?
Well, recall that
in our first example
we showed that A
times B did not have
to be the same as B
times A. In other words,
note that this remark
that A times I sub n
equals I sub n times
A is not redundant.
In general, the
product of two matrices
depends on the order in
which they're written.
And that leads me, then,
into my next subtopic.
And that is, where
is matrix algebra
different from
numerical algebra?
In other words, what
are the differences
between matrix algebra
and the usual algebra?
We've already seen
one difference.
One difference is that A*B need
not equal B*A. In other words,
I could find A and B such that
A times B equals B times A.
But in general, given
A and B at random,
there is no reason to presuppose
that A times B has to equal B
times A. And again, there
are plenty of drill exercises
on this particular point.
The second major
difference between this
and numerical arithmetic is
the existence of inverses.
In other words, given a matrix
A which is not the zero matrix,
the matrix called A
inverse need not exist.
Now what do you
mean by A inverse?
The inverse of a number
means a number such
that when you multiply it by
that given number you get one.
Therefore, inverse
matrices would be what?
An inverse would
be that matrix such
that when you
multiply it by A, you
get the identity matrix I sub n,
in other words, the matrix that
has 0's every place except
1's on the main diagonal.
And what I'm saying is that
whether we like it or not,
it turns out that
given the matrix A,
you cannot always solve the
matrix equation A times X
equals I sub n.
In other words, what it
means in terms of equations
is given n equations
and n unknowns,
you may not always be able
to invert the equations.
In other words, given the y's
in terms of the x's, it's not
always possible to solve
uniquely for the x's in terms
of the y's.
Again, I'm just trying to
give you an overview here.
So a more detailed
remark or an explanation
about what I'm saying will be in
the notes and in the exercises.
But the key point is that not
all matrices are invertible.
And again, the easiest
way to see this
is to explicitly go into a 2
by 2 matrix and take a look.
Let's take here as an example
the 2 by 2 matrix [1, 2; 2, 4].
Let X be the matrix [x sub
1,1, x sub 1,2; x sub 2,1,
x sub 2,2].
Now, I know how to
multiply two matrices.
I multiply A times X. I
obtain the matrix written down
over here: x sub 1,1 plus 2
x sub 2,1; 2 x sub 1,1 plus 4
x sub 2,1; et cetera.
I sub 2, by definition, is
the matrix [1, 0; 0, 1].
And to say that A
sub X equals I sub 2
means that this
matrix, term by term,
must be the same as this matrix.
In particular, if
we just focus--
let me just get a piece
of chalk over here--
if we just focus our attention
on this having to be the same
as this and this having to
be the same as, this leads
to the fact that (x sub 1,1)
plus 2(x sub 2,1) has to equal
1.
This says that 2(x sub 1,1) plus
4(x sub 2,1) has to equal 0.
And I claim that right away
this shows that it's impossible
for there to be numbers
x_(1,1) and x_(2,1) that exist.
Because, lookit, if we
found two numbers x sub 1,1
and x sub 2,1 that obeyed
these two equations,
we would have
proved that 2 equals
0, which as I told
you before is only
true for small values
of zero, right.
No, lookit, if this
were true, just
multiply both sides
of this equation by 2.
It would say what?
That 2 times x sub 1,1 plus
4 times x sub 2,1 equals 2.
But at the same time, that
same quantity must equal 0.
And since this is impossible, it
means that this matrix does not
exist.
In other words, it is
impossible-- we've just
shown it-- to find
numbers that I can plug in
here such that when I multiply
this matrix by this matrix,
I get this matrix.
That's the best proof that
A inverse need not exist.
Namely what?
Show one matrix A for which
A inverse doesn't exist.
That's all you have to do to
show that an inverse doesn't
have to exist.
Just show one case.
One counterexample is
all it takes, right.
So what's the point?
The point is we must
beware of results
which require A inverse.
Well let's think back
to ordinary arithmetic.
What results required the
existence of an inverse?
Well, for example, in
ordinary arithmetic,
if the product of two numbers
was 0, one of the factors
had to be 0.
And we proved that by
multiplying both sides
of the equation by A inverse.
Well, we don't have inverses
necessarily in matrix algebra.
So for example,
in matrix algebra,
it's possible that the
product of two matrices
gives you the zero matrix, yet
neither of the two matrices
itself is the zero matrix.
Or, another
consequence of inverse,
in matrix multiplication
it's possible
that A times B can equal A
times C, yet A need not be 0
nor B need equal
C. In other words,
we can have A times B equals
A times C even though A is not
the zero vector and
B is not equal to C.
Again, the beauty of
an arithmetic course
is that we don't
have to hand wave.
We can make the emotional,
subjective statements,
but we can back them
up simply by showing
the existence of examples.
So to illustrate my claims here,
let me just do this, as I say,
by means of an example.
Let's take the matrix
that we took in example 2.
Let A be the matrix
[1, 2; 2,  4].
Is that the zero matrix?
No, it's not the zero matrix.
Why?
Because the zero matrix
must have zero entries
every place, and this doesn't
have zero entries every place.
Let's just, out of the hat, pull
out the matrix [2, 2; -1, -1].
And again, without going through
every single detail here,
if I multiply this
matrix times this matrix,
the result is the zero matrix.
For example just by way of
illustration, 1 times 2 is 2.
2 times minus 1 is minus 2.
2 plus minus 2 is 0.
That accounts for the 0 here.
If I check this
whole thing through,
I will find that every
entry here must be 0.
Therefore, I have what?
Two matrices, neither of
which is the zero matrix,
yet their product
is the zero matrix.
On the other hand, let me
now take the same matrix,
[1 2; 2 4] and multiply
that by another matrix
that I pull out of the hat.
The one I'm gonna pull out
of the hat is [-2, -6; 1, 3].
And again, just to do a
quick check over here,
let's check the product in
the second row, second column.
It's what?
2 times minus 6 is minus 12.
4 times 3 is 12.
Minus 12 plus 12 is 0.
In other words, this times
this, neither matrix here
is the zero matrix, yet the
product is a zero matrix.
And by the way, before I
make a further comment here,
let me say I didn't really
pull these out of the hat.
I leave this as an
exercise for you to do.
But there are
infinitely many matrices
that I can multiply this matrix
by and get the zero matrix.
In fact, all I have
to do is make sure
that the matrix I
multiply this by
has the property that
the first row is minus
twice the second row.
And if you don't know
where I get that from,
all I do is what?
I solve, again, the
matrix equation.
I let X be the matrix
I'm looking for.
I take [1, 2; 2, 4], multiply
it by X, equate it to 0,
and see what conditions are
imposed on my coefficients.
Again, this is not the
point of our overview here.
You can do that in
the homework exercises
in the reading material.
But the key point is,
what I have done is what,
as far as this is concerned?
Look at these two examples.
This matrix times this
one is the zero matrix.
This times this is
the zero matrix.
Therefore, this times this is
the same as this times this.
Notice that this term
equals this term, right.
And what I'm driving at is
that here is a case where
this is not the zero matrix.
The second factors are
not equal to each other.
You see this matrix does
not equal this matrix.
Yet when I cancel
this, I can not
conclude that this matrix
equals this matrix.
In other words,
here I have what?
A times B equals A times C.
Yet A is not the zero matrix,
and the matrix B is not
equal to the matrix C.
And so what have I proven?
I've proven that it is
not necessarily true
that for matrices, when it
comes to cancellation of factors
when you're
multiplying, that you
can take the same
liberties that you
can in numerical arithmetic.
And this is a very
troublesome thing.
This bothers people.
It means that we have to be
particularly careful when
we do the arithmetic of
matrices to make sure
that we're dealing with what?
Invertible matrices.
What it means, again, is that
if the system of equations that
the matrix is coding is such
that the matrix does not have
an inverse, it means that
somehow or other we cannot
invert the system of equations.
And so what we do in the
study of matrix algebra
is we single out a
particularly important subset
of the matrices.
Namely, we have a special
interest in those matrices A
for which A inverse exists.
And because we have that
special interest, what
we do is we define a matrix,
give it a special name
if it has an inverse.
Namely, a definition is what?
The matrix A is
called non-singular
provided A inverse exists.
Now what's the beauty of
non-singular matrices?
The beauty of
non-singular matrices
is if you happen
to know that you're
dealing with a
non-singular matrix,
then you can take the
same arithmetic liberties
that you could with numbers.
For example, let me just give
you an illustration here.
Suppose I know that A*B
equals A*C where A, B,
and C are matrices.
And I happen to also know that A
is non-singular, in other words
that A inverse exists.
I claim that with this
extra piece of information,
provided I know that
A is non-singular,
I claim that from
A*B equals A*C,
I can conclude that B equals
C. Not only can I conclude it,
but I can conclude it as
a corollary to numerical
arithmetic.
Because remember, how did we
prove in numerical arithmetic
that you could
have cancellation?
All it required was that
the number being canceled
had to have an inverse.
I can parrot the
proof word for word.
Namely, I'm given that
A*B equals A*C. I say, OK,
I will therefore multiply both
sides of the equation by A
inverse.
How do I know I could
multiply by A inverse?
Well, all I need to know
is that A inverse exists.
But how do I know then
that A inverse does exist?
Well, I said that
A is non-singular
and by definition that
means that A inverse exists.
So I multiply both
sides by A inverse.
Now, I also know that
multiplication is associative.
That's one of my
rules of the game.
So I switch the voice
inflection, the parentheses.
In other words, the
fact that this is true
means that this is true.
See, I just switched
the voice inflection.
But by definition, what
property does A inverse have?
It has the property that
A inverse multiplied by A
gives you the identity
matrix, I sub n.
In other words,
from this statement
I can conclude that I sub n
times B equals I sub n times C.
But what property
does I sub n have?
It has the property that when
it multiplies any matrix,
it does not change that matrix.
Therefore I sub
n times B is just
B. I sub n times C is just
C. And I've concluded what?
That, as a theorem, it follows
inescapably in other words,
that if A is non-singular,
then if A*B equals A*C,
B must equal C. And this is step
by step the same proof that we
used for numbers, except
that we had to use what?
I sub n instead of 1.
If we just recopy
this, this is what?
Structurally, we cannot
distinguish the proof here from
the proof that we gave
in numerical arithmetic.
Now the question
that comes up is,
how do you determine whether a
matrix is non-singular or not?
Are there any cute recipes.
And we've already, in this
course, for different reasons,
talked about 2 by 2 determinants
and 3 by 3 determinants.
Determinants get messy when you
go up to higher than 3 by 3.
Worse then messy,
they become deceptive
because the obvious recipes
turn out to be false.
And the correct recipes
turn out to be ones
that you rebel against using
because somehow you're not
used to them and like
to believe there's
a simpler way of doing it.
I am going to save the
precise study of determinants
for a later block of material.
But I just want to mention
one interesting thing in terms
of determinants and why
determinants come up
in the studies of systems
of linear equations.
And that is, the
role of determinants
is this-- and more
details will be supplied
in a later block-- the
matrix A is non-singular if
and only if its
determinant is not 0.
In other words, the
existence of A inversed
is equivalent to the fact that
the determinant of the given
matrix is not 0.
Now this is a messy proof.
So I will restrict the proof
to that case when n equals 2.
Because in the case
n equals 2, it's
rather easy to multiply
these matrices together.
For example, let's suppose I
take the matrix [a, b; c, d].
In other words, we'll
call this the matrix A.
And I want to see, what should
I multiply that matrix by
to get the identity matrix?
In other words, under
what conditions can
I invert the matrix
[a, b; c,  d]?
Well, what that means is I want
to find [x 1, x2; y 1, y 2]
such that when I multiply
these two matrices together,
I get this matrix.
Now, notice what this leads to.
For example, this
times this is what?
It's a*x_1 plus b*y_1,
but that must equal 1.
Similarly, this times
this is c*x_1 plus d*y_1,
and that must equal
this, which is 0.
And that means what?
To find x_1 and y_1, I have
to be able to solve the system
of equations a*x_1
plus b*y_1 equals 1.
c*x_1 plus d*y_1 equals 0.
Oh, similarly, it
also has to be true
that when I multiply the first
row by the second column,
I have to get 0.
The second row here by
the second column here,
I have to get 1.
That also gives me this
system of equations.
Notice by the way, that
the matrix of coefficients
on both of these two
systems is the same.
The matrix of
coefficients is what?
In both cases, the matrix of
coefficients is [a, b; c, d].
Now here's the point.
In order to get a unique
solution here-- remember,
both of these two equations,
each of these two equations
represents the equation
of a straight line.
The only way you can get
one and only one solution
is when the straight
lines are not parallel.
You see, if the two
straight lines are parallel,
if they're different
straight lines,
there are no intersections.
And if they happen
to coincide, you
have infinitely
many intersections.
So the only time
you're in trouble here
is if these two lines
happen to be parallel.
Algebraically, that says what?
That the ratio b over a is the
same as the ratio d over c.
In other words, the
unique solubility
of these systems of equations
requires only that b over a
be unequal to d over c.
Well, another way of
saying that is what?
That a times d minus b
times c be unequal to 0.
But what is a*d minus b*c?
a*d minus b*c is the determinant
of the matrix [a, b; c, d].
In other words, in
the two by two case,
the matrix is
invertible if and only
if its determinant of
coefficients is not 0.
At least that proves it
for the two by two case.
Let's check it out in
a couple of examples.
Let's go back again to our old
friend from examples 2 and 3.
Let A be the matrix
[1, 2; 2,  4].
The determinant of
coefficients is 1 times
4, which is 4, minus 2
times 2, which is also 4.
4 minus 4 is 0.
The determinant A is 0.
Therefore, according to
our theorem A is singular.
By the way, I guess
I've slipped here.
I haven't defined
what singular means.
I think it's rather obvious.
Singular is an abbreviation
for non-non-singular.
In other words, if it's
false that the matrix is
non-singular, then
we call it singular.
In other words, A does
not have an inverse
because its determinant is 0.
And this checks with
our previous result
when we showed that A
inverse didn't exist.
OK.
Let me pick one more example to
conclude today's lesson with.
Let's take the
matrix A now to be
the matrix whose first row is
[5, 4] and whose second row
is [7, 6].
Then, how do we find
the determinant again?
It's 5 times 6, which is 30,
minus 7 times 4, which is 28.
30 minus 28.
Well, it happens to be 2.
But the key factor
is that it's not 0.
In other words, the
determinant of A is not 0.
Therefore, according
to our general theory,
A inverse exists.
And now, we come to why I
have to give a second lecture
on this particular topic.
You see, what I
have done now is I
have finished matrix algebra as
far as the qualitative overview
is concerned.
But the major problem in
working with matrices,
and the one which I will solve
next time, is the following.
If I'm given a matrix
A, and I know somehow
or other the
determinant is not 0,
or equivalently, somebody tells
me that the A inverse exists,
the question is, knowing
that A inverse exists,
how do we actually determine
the value of A inverse?
You see, there's
two problems here.
One is, given a
system of equations,
say you have n equations with
n unknowns where y_1 up to y_n
are expressed in terms of x_1 up
to x_n, the first question is,
is it possible to solve for
the x's in terms of the y's.
Now, if the answer to that
question is no, we quit.
But if the answer is
yes, the next question--
and from a practical
point of view
this is often crucial--
the next question is,
knowing that we can solve for
the x's in terms of the y's,
how do we actually carry
out this computation?
And the matrix
equivalence is this.
Given the matrix A, A
inverse need not exist.
But if A inverse does
exist, how do we compute it?
And that will be the subject
of our lecture next time,
how to compute A inverse.
And a corollary to
this will be, how
is this related to
solutions of systems of n
equations in n unknowns?
But we'll talk more
about that next time.
And until next time, good bye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabrielle
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.